-You're gonna go on tour.
Smashing Pumpkins,
through the fall.
And how is touring these days?
I've heard you say
that it's less fun
being on a bus for six weeks
-With guys.
-With guys, yeah.
Used to be, yeah, in the '90s,
but I got my own bus now.
-Oh, gotcha.
So you're solo bus?
-I've got my 11-piece band
all squashed up
in a little camper van,
and I've got a huge bus
about the size of this studio.
Touring America, like, "Great.
[ Laughter ]
-Do the other --
Do they resent you, you think,
your 11-person band,
that you have this lovely bu
to yourself?
-I thought so, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't feel it on stage,
though.
-Not particularly.
-Okay. That's good.
-It's my name
on the poster, so...
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good way
of looking at it.
You're also touring with U
in Australia in November.
-That's right.
-And I heard that you and Bono
had a night where you sang
karaoke together.
And yet there's no --
no memory of it.
-Well, apparently --
Apparently, they had a party
for the crew in Bogotá,
and apparently we did karaoke,
and we did the song,
"Kung Fu Fighting."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And, apparently --
You haven't got footage of this?
-No, no, I swear we don't.
[ Laughter ]
-And, apparently,
we did the moves, as well.
-Yeah, you did some
kung fu fighting.
-So they say.
[ Laughter ]
But, I mean,
it was full of Irish peopl
who will notoriously
exaggerate everything.
-Could've been
some just soft kicking.
-I mean, I genuinely have no
recollection of it whatsoever.
Neither does he.
-Wow.
It's one of those lovely myths
that we will never know
whether it was true or not
-I mean,
thank God no one's got footage
[ Laughter ]
-How is it for you now?
I mean, obviously,
you've been doing this
for a long time.
How have your fans,
how have the concerts change
20, 25 years into doing this
-It's, uh --
I guess, uh...
I've got young kids coming
and I've become quite the thin
for middle-aged women.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
On my last tour in America
we did a gig somewhere
up north in the snow,
and it was --
There was like three women
on the front row,
and it became apparent that on
of these women was a huge fa
and the other two weren't.
[ Laughter ]
And I was halfway
through a song,
and I'm giving it the [bleep
-Yeah.
-And one of the women
on the front row,
she's doing this with her phone.
And she just goes...
[ Laughter ]
And she looks over,
sees me looking at her,
she just goes, "Sorry."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm kind of playing her,
going, "I'm sorry about that."
[ Laughter ]
"Go buy a T-shirt."
-What about you?
You have three kids?
Is that right?
-I do have three kids.
-Do they have a connection
to your music?
-Well, it's kind of a rule
They've got to kind of fak
a little bit of interest in it
-Okay.
-Even at a lower level,
they've got to go, "Yeah, yeah
It's a great song."
[ Laughter ]
They like -- They like
the modern hip-hop, Kanye,
and all that kind of thing
-Okay, gotcha.
-They're kind of into it.
You know, they've got to b
into it because, you know,
they're gonna benefit from it.
-Yeah.
-At some point.
-Down the line, yeah.
This is sort of --
This is a big deal for them.
You're sort of famously --
Your football club
is Manchester City,
coming off an incredible season.
-Amazing.
-Amazing season.
And, you know, we sort of
from a distance know there are
two big clubs in Manchester --
Manchester United,
Manchester City.
-Well, we don't mention
the other one.
-We don't mention the other one.
Well, we were talking
about your kids
and how they sort of are -
You know, you asked them to be
a little bit of fans.
What would happen if one o
your kids wanted to be a fan
of the other Manchester team
-[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Laughter ]
That would be tough.
I mean, I'd probably drive him
as far away
from my house as possible.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll leave him
on the motorway.
[ Laughter ]
-The point would come across
-These things get sorted out
quite quickly in Manchester.
It's just like, you know -
You say to, like, a baby,
"You don't know this yet.
You don't know this yet.
But you're gonna support City,
and that's the end of it."
-That's it.
That's the end of it.
-So you have had no troubl
on that front.
-No, no, they're kind of
big into it, and they --
I mean, when they first came
to the matches, like all kids,
they've got the attention span
of a small flea.
-Yeah.
What's the right age,
did you find?
When can they finally engage
-I've brought my eldest so
when he was about 7.
And, you know, kids now,
they're onto social media,
so he brought his iPad
to the match.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"I'm not sure
you're gonna need that."
[ Laughter ]
And he ended up on it,
you know.
Because the match is too long.
It's like an hour and a half
They're kind of into it now,
though.